how could we save the crew of the
destiny well apparently Mark Fergus
already has a plan welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
so I've done a couple of videos go back
and check them out about how we could
save the crew of the destiny I've tried
to think of realistic ways based in
Canon stuff we actually know about how
we could have gone and saved them but
then I got a message from one of my
brilliant sources that works in around
MGM and they basically said why didn't
you mention what Mark Fergus said about
that
I went because I don't know what Mark
Fergus said about that
and they came back to me yes you do I
told you
and I went back no you didn't yeah I did
no I didn't get this went on for a
little while
and I had to reassure them that if
they'd have remembered to tell me this
I'd have remembered to tell you guys
so I gotta go back about nine months now
and I actually did talk about this at
the time the source told me they sat in
on a meeting and it was when um MGM were
first approaching Mark Fergus about
potentially bringing back the Stargate
franchise it was before they start
negotiating and it was then before
negotiations ended at Christmas
apparently they were just having some
preliminary chats about what Mark Fergus
felt the best targeting what he knows
about Stargate and at one point actually
somebody did mention to him Stargate
Universe and he apparently went on a 45
minute rant about what he would have
done in series 3 of Stargate Universe if
he'd been allowed to have a go I was
really impressed actually of this guy is
a gator and that just really filled me
with confidence that if he does get the
opportunity to bring the Stargate
franchise back then actually the
franchise is in the best hands possible
but what about this that he had already
got a plan about how to bring the
destiny crew home
well
however much my source says they told me
this at the time they didn't
but apparently he did discuss that if he
does the franchise he wants to bring the
crew home he says that storyline 100
needs to be tied off now anybody that
wants to see a third fourth fifth season
of Stargate Universe is going to be
disappointed it's not going to happen
Mark Fergus said though that he would
love it to be part of maybe the
overarching story in one of the seasons
that we would actually get to see quite
a lot of what happens on the destiny 10
or 15 years after the events of the
series that he would keep it within a
time frame that made sense that much of
the crew initially would probably still
be in stasis it would explain why David
blue looks completely different
because he's been surviving on the
Destiny for over a decade and if it was
up to Mark Fergus he wouldn't send us
out to go and save the crew they'd save
themselves with the help of the planet
builders
now the planet Builders were a species
that we either did or didn't see in
Stargate Universe it's a little bit
confusing they sort of hint that it was
a dream and then they hint that it
wasn't and then they sort of say that
the whole thing was into Mario Hansen's
brain that actually it was the AI for
the destiny the sort of generated the
storyline and actually maybe the planet
Builders didn't exist at all
but actually then Joseph malozi was one
of the co-creators of the series did
talk about how if they'd have got a
third season of Stargate Universe we
would have seen the planet Builders
again which does suggest at least in
malosi's mind that they were real
somehow Mark Fergus was apparently
intrigued by the possibility of this
race that he wanted to understand a race
that was potentially even more powerful
than the Ancients and that he felt that
if the Destiny was going to come home
not just the crew the destiny herself
that the planet Builders were the one
race that was potentially able to do
that
now apparently Mark Fergus would have
loved to have tied this all into the
storyline about why the Destiny was out
so far in the first place searching for
this hidden message in the background
radiation of the universe now he said
his first thought was to make the planet
Builders the race that actually sent
that signal so they would have been a
god-like race that were older maybe than
time but apparently in this meeting he
did talk about how that was maybe too
big
and then you need to rain in a little
bit but actually that the planet
Builders were a race of people that had
detected the background radiation signal
themselves and had gone out looking for
that signal that maybe they had touched
the face of God but they weren't
actually Gods themselves but whatever
they had learned had then changed them
forever he said he wanted to see this
race of people to be beyond anything the
Ancients were capable of but also beyond
the ascended beings so they really would
have been in lots of ways the most
powerful race of beings we've ever seen
more than capable of returning the
destiny home
now Mark Fergus didn't go into why they
would send them home why would they
choose to help these people or anything
like that but he did offer up one other
interesting possibility he basically
said that we'd seen Russia's development
and evolution through the first two
seasons of Stargate Universe and he
wanted to test that Evolution he says
what if Rush was given a choice
and that choice was that you can either
touch the face of God yourself that you
can learn more about the message
or you the destiny and your crew could
be saved but you can't have both
now this would be a moral dilemma for
rush but also a a test by the planet
builders
testing Humanity in a way through Rush
what rush then decided Mark Fergus
didn't go into any more details
but the fact that he was considering
that much detail does suggest he's
really considered the possibilities for
a Stargate franchise now I have to admit
I'm really excited by the possibilities
that Mark Fergus has allegedly suggested
in this meeting I'm irritated that my
source didn't tell me nine months ago
you didn't tell me you didn't
but I really think that it's a
fascinating insight into the mind of the
person that's potentially going to be
bringing the Stargate franchise back a
person that does love Stargate a person
that has genuinely considered many of
the possibilities about bringing the
franchise back and doing more than just
creating a new show but creating a new
show that harks back to the original
creating a new show the Gators and new
viewers can both love equally and I
really really enjoy the fact that Mark
Fergus has had these ideas playing
around in his head for quite some time
he went into this meeting pretty much
blind he didn't know he was going to be
asked about Stargate Universe but he
ended up pulling this idea from
somewhere
that suggests to me this is a singular
mind a person that is quite actually
obsessive about what he does and that is
the sort of person that I desperately
want in charge of the new Stargate
franchise this guy could be our Kevin
fight he could be the guy that leads
Stargate back to where it belongs not
just to rival Star Trek as one of the
most popular sci-fi franchises on
television but to overtake it
let's just hope Amazon get off their
backsides and give him the opportunity
but guys I'd love to know exactly what
you think about some of these ideas
obviously we need to put a little bit
more meat on the bones we've only got a
few quick thoughts out of Mark fergus's
head but they're fascinating thoughts
that I'd love to see if you guys could
make some sense of and maybe add a bit
of detail to let your imaginations run
Riot get into the comments if you are
new to the Channel please like subscribe
hit that Bell notification it really
helps us out and you'll never miss any
of our new videos also you can go to
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack
where most of our new videos air first
and for a small contribution each month
you also get a free gift after three
months you get to see those videos first
and without the adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign
[Music]